the great columnist for the Cleveland
Plain Dealer bill Livingston bill we got
drama was this expected by anyone that
you're firing the GM it was a surprise
to me dan Gilbert is kind of a tough guy
to work with
he has been extended any of the general
managers he's had but I thought I
thought David Griffin had demonstrably
done such a good job he should be
allowed to continue and if they if it's
true and I believe it to be true that
they had diverse opinions on how the
franchise where the franchise stood
competitors competitively against Golden
State and what moves should be made in
the future I think then Gilbert should
sign the checks and let us basketball
people make the basketball decisions all
right let's look short term long term
and are they two different goals
therefore this franchise of what is
happening now in the next year and then
what happens with LeBron James and the
franchise after that well it's always
now with the Cavaliers it has been since
he came since James came back because
he's 32 now figure he's got two maybe 35
as a as the player he is now are close
to one of the best players in the league
he's the best right now it's it's always
been win now ever since he came back and
possibly that was something Griffin
didn't really enjoy because he didn't
have a lot of moves he could make there
so far over the salary cap and into the
luxury tax but with what he had to work
with he did a pretty good job he had
some misses yeah you know Kyle Korver
didn't play very well in the playoffs
but it was a defensible move and and it
had the chance to work out and a lot of
his moves did work out I think it's the
biggest screwup Gilbert's made sense he
set the letter out Wow alright what's
this mean because I and I guess let's
part the Red Sea here did they get are
they getting Jimmy Butler it was there
I guess maybe dissension on do we want
Jimmy Butler go all in is Dan Gilbert
kind of preparing also for Armageddon if
and when LeBron leaves again and how
does that factor in with what the game
plan is here well that's all those are
good questions I would prefer to have
Jimmy Gilbert or Jimmy Butler myself
over Paul George I just think he's a
better player at the position and but
you know I'm not I wouldn't trade Kevin
Love III think that would I don't think
Indiana really wants love they won't
draft picks and the Cavs just don't have
them
I think this I've always thought that
there was tension that lasted between
LeBron and Gilbert of course now we know
it's true ESPN thing and also as I wrote
this morning before the World Series in
the end the Cavs ring ceremony was going
to be on the same night and Gilbert
moved the start of the Cavs game up an
hour which was a nice move so people
could we had tickets to both could see
more of the baseball game and if Ron was
asked by an out-of-towner who didn't
know the dynamic very well what does
this say about Gilbert and LeBron said I
don't know what do you think it says
about him it's a softball question you
know and obviously there's still some
blank are on James's part I certainly
don't think this improves the chances
that LeBron will stay after 2018
and as I've written before it's
different with a guy who broke a 52-year
drought yeah I mean he's not the same
guy who was when he left we're not the
same people we were when we were bitter
about him leaving
he had a great magnanimity about himself
to try to help people in this in the
city he delivered the championship he
promised if he wants to go play with his
friends in LA Chris Paul and in Carmelo
Anthony I just say have a good rest of
your life it was a gasp watching me play
and I hope most people would feel that
way I don't know if they will bill I do
see do you think LeBron ends his career
in Cleveland No
not no I don't not with the not with the
problems with Gilbert and I do think he
wants to have a run with his buddies and
you know people can be better about that
if they want to be I think you kind of
guys some slack when he's done what he's
done what did the Cavaliers do here in
the next couple of weeks that will
improve the roster dramatically I don't
really know what they can do they don't
have a whole lot to offer other than
Kevin Love and you know I just that's
always been a problem that's why Gilbert
I think screwed up by letting him go he
did a good job with with not a whole lot
of resources they've been you know you
look back on it he promised a
championship before the one in Miami
before LeBron won in Miami which was
ridiculous they were the worst team in
the league for four years one of the
reasons that they're a really good team
now is they've been insanely lucky in
the lottery they got LeBron with the
lottery they got Kyrie Irving with the
lottery that got Andrew Wiggins who was
the trade bait for love all his number
one picks in the lottery no they also
got Anthony Bennett in a bad year but
that's the way it goes you know luck and
and LeBron when you come back and help
us help us hometown it's not anything
particularly that the Cavs did although
Chris grant and and Griffin were good at
assembling you know accruing assets and
contracts and things like that but it's
certainly not a whole lot of brilliance
on the Cavs part is Kyrie off limits I
would think so yes I think so he's he's
closer 1a and you know he doesn't play a
whole lot of defense and he had an
up-and-down playoffs but and he can win
a big game for you he want a
championship for them and he's 25 years
old but does Jimmy but at a lower rim
finisher I've ever seen did have seen
him since I roll Earl the Pearl does
Jimmy Butler make them a better team to
face Golden State than Kevin Love in the
line yeah I think so
because love his numbers
his numbers were good overall but you
know like in game 5 there are times
where he just doesn't come up that big
in big games but you know he was an
all-star this year and and he had a good
he had a good season he just you know
liked like some other guys he didn't
play as well as he hoped he would in the
finals that's a tough matchup for
anybody going to state though especially
now that they've got Durant you know I
mean that's just ridiculous but he had
the right to do it do you think that
LeBron could have saved David Griffin's
jeong-ah
well we would have I think he could have
I think he would have but why I know I
had a lot of respect for Griffin he's
sent out tweet tweet to that effect and
I know we appreciated the things he did
given that his hands were tied by the
economic situation so much but why would
Gilbert do this if he knows it's going
to upset LeBron James and the Griffin
had done a good job and maybe Griffin
you know I think he was effectively
fired I think you know if they had
divergent views on the franchise Gilbert
should have just said well we'll give it
another run with you because we've been
in the finals for three straight years
and he didn't want to do that so I think
that is effectively firing him I don't
know why did Gilbert send out the letter
you know why did he make ridiculous high
and this guy promises because he's Dan
Gilbert does he talk to the local media
no certainly not to me oh sorry just to
be honest about it now that's probably a
good thing that he doesn't talk to you
that means they probably realized yeah
you know better do respected than love
that's true that's true
thank you Bill keep fighting the good
fight and thank you all right bill
Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
I didn't get screw up like how do you
just went to the finals again you you
want a title last year and here you are
Golden State has gotten into everybody's
head they're all going there whack jobs
now the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you